tik-tok pensions like the hype house are
a hotbed of social interaction and
entertainment but what does that mean
now that there are government
recommendations for social distancing
keep watching to find out what current
events mean for all your favorite tick
tock stars the entire point of any type
of creative collective is to bring
artists together these tick tock
mansions are no different
tick tock mansions like hype House have
a bunch of stars living together
creating content and building their
brands but now that the world is
supposed to be observing social
distancing what is light that a tick
tock mansion look like it's going to be
different for a while of course first
major events have been canceled like
March Madness and South by Southwest
then government started suggesting that
any gatherings of over 250 people be
disbanded now the recommendation is for
groups of more than 15 people to cancel
there are more than 15 people living in
tik-tok mansions the hype house has 19
residents that come and go
there are also recommendations for
travel there are some areas of the
United States that are better off than
others so it's a good idea not to travel
to spread any unwanted germs but most of
the tick tock stars don't live there
full-time they'll travel or go home and
then come back and stay for a few weeks
but this isn't recommended given the
current situation obviously some major
things are going to have to change one
of these major changes will affect tick
tock errs living situations
technically mansions like hype house and
sway house are private homes a few of
the residents are on the lease it's not
likely that the government will shut
down these houses since they aren't
exactly like hotels or Airbnb s however
it is possible that the landlord's may
step in tight the house isn't owned by
tick tock stars
if landlords decide that having that
many people in a rental property is a
risk they
slap on some regulations they might
decide to not let any of the transient
members of the home come in since
they've been traveling the leaders of
the house could also decide to limit how
many people are coming in and out the
mansion residents are allowed to have
guests which would increase the number
of people together that will likely be
the first rule to go you can probably
count on fewer guest appearances in your
tick-tock videos of course since the
tic-tock mansions are used to making
money there might be a government
loophole some states have closed resorts
and state parts other states are
implementing curfews if they step in the
stars could be cast out and ordered to
leave the full-time residents of type
house will probably stay that's where
they live permanently but now that Daisy
keeps is doing her own thing that's
really just Alex warren thomas petrol
and Kivar a nun that big house is going
to get lonely also what if they can't
pay rent on the big mansion they count
on the rent from the other residents
that come and go they might be forced to
say goodbye to hype house in the coming
months depending on how long the social
distancing rule remains in place they
could also limit the amount of tick tock
stars that live in the house for a while
if they stay under 10 or 15 people
they'll comply with the best
recommendations but since people
shouldn't be traveling no one else
should come in during that time we'll be
curious to see what the tick tock
mansions decide to do where will they go
many of the tick tock stars who live at
Hythe house are still underage so they
never really lived at the mansion
full-time these stars will likely return
home to their families some of the older
ones might - they could also be forced
to run a smaller home if the mansions
were to get shut down hopefully they've
prepared a safety net for times like
these but what changes can we expect in
terms of content if they aren't filming
in the tic-tock mansions what sort of
new tic toc videos will we be seeing a
lot of these stars could go back to
filming solo videos like they did before
they join the hype house in late 2019
we'd love some throwback style videos on
our tick-tock feeds but since people are
supposed to be limiting social
interaction we'll probably see less of
these ensemble
videos for the time being or maybe we'll
get a whole new glimpse into these stars
lives these are creative people so we're
sure they'll keep things exciting they
could include their families and pets
even more some of the tick tock stars
also have parents and siblings who are
part of the tick tock world there could
be a whole new meaning to family
entertainment stars that don't do
lifestyle videos might even surprise us
tick stalkers that are well known for
their singing and dancing videos could
venture into new talents the
possibilities are endless also is there
anything better than watching great
singers sing their songs while they wash
their hands it's pretty hilarious and
encourages people to stay clean social
distancing can also give us even more
tick tock stars think about it pretty
soon people could get bored and decide
to open a tick tock account of their own
they'll start trying new things and
making tick tock videos can be a lot of
fun all you really need is a smartphone
and the internet but people can get into
video editing as a new hobby there could
be individuals who have been wanting to
share their talents like singing with
the world but they haven't had the time
we anticipate a bunch of new stars
putting themselves out there to
entertain people and make new
connections there's going to be some
great comedy content too people are
going to do silly things and record it
just because they're bored bring it on
tick tock we're ready the tick tock
mansions have also brought us a lot of
drama there's some major beef happening
between Daisy peach and Thomas Daisy
doesn't feel she's gotten enough credit
for her work sounding hype house she has
more or less left to do her own thing
and she is planning on starting her own
tick tock mansion but we bet there is no
shortage of drama during these times of
self distancing after all people are
going to be stuck inside together for
long periods of time there might be a
lot of new drama popping up on the app
it just may not be at the mansion
tick tock is also a great way to see how
everyone is handling social distancing
schools and workplaces are encouraging
their stew
and staff members to work from home
people are going to get bored and
producing relatable content will help
them connect with each other some of our
more talented tik-tok errs will also
have some ideas for staying busy new
pranks new projects new dances there
will be so many videos with ideas to
keep everyone who is practicing social
distancing feeling lightly and
entertained all things decide what a
social distancing mean for the future of
tick-tock well tick-tock stars make most
of their living through the app and
other forms of social media they have
millions of followers on all of their
accounts but should they be worried
about losing their income probably not
people are going to be consuming even
more entertainment content think about
it if you're at home you want to do
something entertaining right the
entertainment industry is jumping on
this trend Disney Plus even released
frozen too early to combat boredom
anymore peak hours kids won't be at
school all day they might take tick-tock
breaks in the middle of their virtual
learning people that haven't downloaded
the app will get bored with their usual
phone apps and might try tick-tock the
only thing that might happen is a
decrease in ad revenue some businesses
will not be investing in social
influencers and advertisement campaigns
but we're sure other businesses will be
there to pick up the slack but what
about when everything is back to normal
tick tock is growing fast but is it
growing too fast a lot of stars have
started banking on their tick-tock
success sure they've become influencers
on social media sites like Instagram but
let's take a look at social app history
tick tock is a lot like vine there were
vine stars like Cameron Dallas and Zach
king even Joe Josie wah and the Ziggler
sisters had a fan base on vine that
didn't watch Dance Moms the vine doesn't
exist anymore
then there was musically we got a lot of
talented singers from that app it led to
a lot of people getting discovered tick
tock is doing that for a more diverse
crowd of talented people but it's tick
tock going the way of vine and will its
popularity eventually backfire it's
definitely a possibility so far there
are only four social media sites that
have really stood the test of time
YouTube Facebook Instagram and Twitter
don't appear to be going anywhere but if
something new and better comes along
after tick tock the stars might be in a
bind these stars will have to adapt to a
new platform in order to keep their
success or they'll need to diversify
their brand could Addison Rae be the
next Jo Jo cy and create a brand that's
in every Walmart some of them might go
on to get signed with production
companies or record labels some stars
might think that it's better to jump
ship before a possible crash the German
sisters Lisa and Lenna did exactly this
they once add the most popular account
on Tik Tok they deleted their account
recently to break new ground we're
excited to see if they can maintain
their success outside of tik-tok of
course tic toc might stand the test of
time the shorter content is appealing
and very different from other video
sharing apps either way we're excited
for what's to come
and we just know that we'll be seeing
all sorts of great new content during
this period of social distancing the
tick tock mansions may have to adjust
but the app is still available to
millions of users it's an interesting
time to be a tick tock influencer as
well as a fan original content isn't
going anywhere
however we could see the plan behind
tick tock mansions come crumbling down
in the nearby future but whether that's
a result of social distancing or legal
troubles is up for debate and that's a
wrap how do you think social distancing
will impact creator collectives and tick
tock errs at this time sound off in the
comments thanks for watching give us a
big thumbs up and subscribe to the
things for more great content see you
next time
you